Why is gluten bad for your brain?
so
from a cancer standpoint
gluten is almost never a driver of cancer
However, gluten can be a driver of inflammation. So back to the antibody
Answer of the question before if I have antibodies to the protein in gluten, which is gliadin or a peptide
medium portion of the gliadin protein. Every time I eat protein, I am going to cause inflammation
first in the gut and then I'll elsewhere in the body
so gluten has
In your intestinal tract, you have gluteal morpheid receptors that fire back to the brain. You also have
Casio morpheid receptors that fire back to the refrain that to do a dairy
KC is the protein in dairy
the added is the protein in gluten. So if you have antibodies to gluten or KC
You will fire back into the brain in your cause of inflammatory process in the brain
That's why gluten and dairy can be bad for your brain because it can cause that inflammation in the brain
For any of my videos, I've always said inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of the brain
because of these connections
So if you have inflammation in the brain, then that causes brain fog, that causes all sorts of problems
Now a person who has had had trauma, let's say they've had
post-concussive syndrome, but let's say they've had
Lyme disease on the process of blood-brain variant
Let's say they had vaccine injury that has caused the blood-brain variant. Let's say they had brain cancer or a tumor
So they already had some other source of
damage to the brain
slash inflammation of the brain, slash microglial cell, primed, slash
Antibodies to neural tissue for the brain for motor neuron system
Any of those things are present or have been present to the past
Eating anything that could be causing inflammation in the gut
Not even glued to their dairy
For say anything else that you may have antibodies against your causing inflammation of the gut
You can cause inflammation of the brain as well
That's why anybody that has those things really should do
A CyRX 10
Really a 3x
CyRX array, 3x CyRX array, 4 and CyRX array, 10 would be good
So if you're having serious
And these this goes for even people who have had a lot of chemo, they have chemo brains because that
Has damaged the blood-brain barrier chemo being an oxidizing agent can damage the blood-brain barrier
Which is just a single cell
Protection around the blood vessels of the brain or by the astrocytes. Those can become damaged
By all sorts of toxins and chemicals including chemotherapy
And then things cross that lack of barrier
And get into the brain and cause inflammation of the brain damage cells
The most commonly damaged cells in the brain are these microglial cells
And they can become damaged
Was called primed and those can be just a source of constant inflammation
And again, worst case scenario is that you end up developing antibodies against
Neural tissue, brain tissue
And then you have a problem because you're basically set up for
You know, you have a basically an autoimmune disease of the brain and you're set up for a destruction of neural tissue
Whatever you have antibodies against
So every time you eat anything that's going to cause inflammation or you're exposed to things that are causing inflammation
Or you have inflammation even from exposure to a virus or you get a cold
You're going to damage that which you have antibodies against first and
If it's to neural tissue, you're going to have issues
So
Glitter can be a bad player, but a lot of foods can be a bad player, but so you want to test for those
That's why you would test for foods
Oh, I want to buy a deal with that, but I have breast cancer because you don't want other forms of inflammation that take
You know
Energy you could say away from your immune system that you're trying to kill this cancer
So it's can be wise to test for those. That's why I give you guys access to the autoimmune course
I don't have autoimmune disease. I have cancer. I'm trying to deal with that
Yeah, so still you have core amenities that decrease your body's ability to be able to kill cancer
So the more you can learn about how to find those triggers and deal with those
And remember my book I talk about most people with cancer also have a core vanity of autoimmune disease
So understanding that can be very helpful in your cause to come back
You know cancer
As well, so go to the black bench